hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I've been going through old fort night
footage and looking at the map updates
and strange changes from over the last
two and a half years today we're going
to celebrate the 10 greatest changes to
the landscape in fort night battle
royale history like usual sit your butt
down for 10 minutes and if you'd be so
kind to use code atom arrow in the shop
to keep the series going it'd be much
appreciated and if you think I've missed
anything please let me know your
favorite map change in the comments
below so you ready let's do this number
10 on our list is the first huge map
change ever seen dusty divot on May the
1st 2018 we saw a meteor take out dusty
deep oh yes I say deep oh sorry leaving
a huge crater in the ground not only was
this monumental for the game a season 4
brought in to so many new players it
also began everything we know and love
in a story sense all story lines and map
changes are pretty much new to this
event do you remember the hop rocks
although they overstayed their welcome
they added mobility and straight-up
old-fashioned fun to the game man the
memories are flooding back now the divot
wasn't finished there though as though
Explo by here it was claimed by the
in-game government who built a secret
facility around the meteor do you
remember trying to understand what would
happen next there the final update to
the divot saw the introduction of the
visitor and yeah we all remember what he
started
[Music]
next on our nostalgia list is the
building in Tilted which repeatedly was
destroyed Oh
tilted towers January 2018 if you
remember rightly the day this place was
added to the game it changed everything
it became a great spot for everyone who
wanted instant action and due to the
building's we all had cover in the days
before cranking 90s changed everything
about for tonight but hey this is about
staying positive and enjoying map
changes do you remember the many updates
to tilted there was a single building
which repeatedly was crushed and
demolished it once again started because
of that meteor which sent a small
asteroid to take out this one building
in particular we didn't worry it was
rebuilt it was then hit by Kevin the
cube on his rampage taking out the
building yet again but don't worry it
was rebuilt again it was then hit by an
earthquake and once again slowly rebuilt
over time from a competitive standpoint
this building forever being constructed
allowed wood to be placed near by making
this deathtrap a great place to learn to
farm mats in the city but the crowning
moment of this map change was the
volcano which took out the town
completely and guess what the only
surviving building was that very one it
so happened to be an insurance agency at
that point specializing in protecting
locations after map changes there was a
homage to this inside great touch great
touch indeed
[Music]
at number eight on our list is a secret
change you may not have noticed well
unless you watch my content because I
couldn't shut up about it the stone
family we named them Rock the Dwayne
Johnson Sharon Stone Kid Rock and their
rock viola pebbles their map changes
lasted months beginning in the old
wailing woods when a group of rocks
formed together to become Dwayne this
was followed by his wife a few weeks
later but they were stuck so far apart
would they ever reach each other
luckily a random volcano popped up which
is pretty normal in fortnight the two
were then broken down to rubble again
and over the next eight weeks we saw
them rebuild themselves and find each
other
Rock the Dwayne Johnson found a flower
for his girl and Sharon Stone gave him
the pose no man can refuse a few weeks
later they were married and she fell
pregnant the stone family moved to the
edge of the island and began to raise
their son kid Rock at the farm in the
last updates we saw that son venture out
alone and whilst reaching for a flower
he fell to his death luckily there was a
stone dog on hand to help him out and he
rescued Kid Rock and that was the end of
their story arc I got to admit I adored
this map change series with the rock
family if you liked it - can you write
rock and roll in the comments please
at number 7 on the list is the food
fight let's run it down since the
beginning of fortnight we've had two
major restaurants vying for our
attention up in the north in tomato town
we had the pizza Pitt restaurant and in
the South we had the der burger
restaurant suddenly without warning the
tomato from the top of pizza pit
vanished and we were all perplexed what
the hell was going on here when it
returned it was ancient stone soon after
the entire town was replaced with a
temple worshiping the pizza gods it was
weird
over by the der burger they had their
own problems for closure yep they were
being shut down and overnight our two
favorite restaurants were now deceased
this led to both companies becoming
legit fast food restaurants buying for
our custom all around the map in weekly
updates this food fight became a game
mode it was such a big point and when
both companies set up shop in the same
town and vied for our attention we knew
something was going to happen
one month later they were still trying
to out-build each other and then the
volcano nearby took matters into its own
hands destroying the entire location and
both the der burger and pizza pit
restaurants the food fight was over what
was it we shall see
speaking of the volcano next on our list
is the robot construction after the
island move forward in time the mountain
which was formerly a volcano became a
power plant energizing the bladeless
fans we used to circle the map with the
impending threat of attack the
inhabitants of BR Island began to build
a giant mech to protect us over about a
month we saw the food fight companies
contribute to the war efforts by
supplying a leg each next the tarsal was
created to look like cuddle team leader
and when the arms were added
they added Rex and drift to the amalgam
and finally a bear head was added and
our island was protected from invasion
the battle that ensued at the end of
this was one of the best live events in
Fortnight history in my opinion I loved
it
what about you what was your favorite
part night live event maybe that could
be next week's video if what and I
continue not to update anything we shall
see at number five on the list are the
rift beacons from season x season x
sorrows travel back in time completely
the opposite of season 9 when it wasn't
really time travel it's it's hurt it's
hard to explain isn't it over the entire
season we watch the visitor or the thick
visitor whichever you prefer construct
beacons which when activated caused
breaks in time and space bringing
different dimensions to our reality we
saw retail roll return with a bunch of
zombie husks and fiends to boot
we saw tilted towers first become tilted
town a Wild West inspired no build zone
and later
this became Gotham freakin City come on
that still blows my mind to this day
fortnight became big enough for a Batman
crossover Wow
out of interest if you love Gotham right
I'm that man in the comments and I'll
try and find you but back to those rift
beacons we also saw a failed attempt to
change the old rec center and we saw the
return of starry suburbs and personally
seeing board London fortnight's blew my
mind like so much that season the rift
beacons gave us weekly updates and
brought us so much variation to the map
it needs to be celebrated it was
insanely good
next we have the return of dusty depo as
many players began playing a season four
they completely missed out on the og
dusty thanks to good old time travel and
bending time and space the visitor
brought them back you'd think that it
would be the end here to this map update
but indeed it was actually the start of
the end we saw the Thicke visitor
evolved the containers to put his plan
into action
he removed everything building up his
own bachelor pad this is the place he
built those rift beacons we've been
talking about he slowly added more
content satellite dishes he built his
own supercomputer next we saw
scaffolding erected and finally the
rocket from season four returned to
bring this game round into one full
cycle remember the day we all got
together and watch the end of this great
island what a great experience all
thanks to the return of the og dusty
Depot epic
[Music]
we've hit the top three but before we
crack on let's give a quick gg to some
other changes that didn't make the top
ten the stage constructed from
marshmallows show in pleasant park the
addition of the villains hidden layer
under hero's mansion the mind-blowing
chair and TV house in West world we had
some great times in fortnight all
because of map changes but now let's
move on to our top three of all time at
number three is polar peak back in
season 7 it was Christmastime and the
battle pass and map updates reflected
that I mean an entire extra section of
the island appeared covered completely
in snow and ice over time we all
realized something was under all that
ice and snow we waited and waited and
waited for the snow to melt and we
weren't let down
first the infinity blade thawed out and
completely ruined the game it was
fantastic to watch the competitive
players complaining but complaining for
a real reason rather than just
complaining like they usually do soon
after that was bolted it had to be and
we saw a castle in the ice when the thaw
reached the lower levels the prisoner
was revealed frozen in place upstairs
there were some clues to be found the
gods of earth wind fire and water had
their own table upstairs with one chair
thrown down as if they were taken away
well we found him and the day came to
see his face but no he escapes before we
could but he got even better
he became the secret character and at
the end of the season he was also the
guy which created the volcano which
impacts so much on the island and this
wasn't the end of the map changes at
polar peak when the volcano took its
revenge and hit the frozen mountain it
revealed an alien eye in the rock face
watching and waiting to be freed the
final update to polar peak saw the
monster escaped and I think we all know
how that story ended robot fist in the
face good times
here we go we've reached second on the
list and it's best amazed by this
sometimes it's the smaller things in
life which bring us happiness the hut
watch we kept an eye on for over a year
had zero impact on the story of
fortnight it affected nothing at all
yet we are sat and waited for the
erection of all erections that should be
a t-shirt going back in time the OG hut
was destroyed by Kevin the cube and sat
dormant for months until a tiny update
saw materials dropped off and two weeks
later construction began every fortnight
I mean every two weeks fo RT ni ght not
the other one every fortnight cut watch
would grow and evolve our community had
competitions to bottle flip off this
sexy monkey fluffer and people made
different building predictions to see
how it would grow what showed me that it
wasn't only me who appreciated the
smaller map updates and at the time I
really hope that impacted epic games -
Hut watch will suddenly be missed
but I have a sneaking suspicion it will
return keep an eye out and give me a
shout if you ever see it again
[Music]
here we go the greatest map changes in
fortnight history and we've reached
number one and I think you know which
update affected the aisle in the most
it's none other than everyone's best
friend Kevin the cube Kevin first
appeared in the desert biome after a
group of cacti were destroyed by freak
lightning bolts I was lucky enough to be
in game that day when Kevin arrived and
it was definitely an epic game a moment
Kevin gave us months of map changes as
he rolled slowly around the map we
attempted to stop him with builds and we
used him as a weapon to eliminate other
players rolling kevin was a god to us
all finally though after he destroyed a
few buildings he made his way to loot
Lake and when he reached it his final
act was to give us a bouncing loot lake
for a few days he wasn't finished with
us or the map for that matter
his legacy continued as he rose back up
and reclaimed his dominance it's thanks
to Kevin we saw the floating island move
around continuously for one season
keeping the game feeling fresh Kevin
brought us fought nightmares Kevin
revealed the bunker to us who'd have
thought a random in-game event many
people missed could become so important
to the world of font Knight even now his
legacy continues and steamy stacks I'm
pretty confident that kevin will return
and all those map updates we long to see
will come back with him fingers crossed
epic please bring back regular map
changes they keep us coming back each
week
so that's our list what do you think do
you agree do you disagree would you put
things in a different order I'll be in
the comments to see what you think as
always a humongous shout out to these
people who've used cold Adam are you in
the shop over the last two weeks you
make these videos possible and I am
humbled by your support thank you so
much if you don't see your name please
know I'm a few days behind on my DMS but
I will get to you
as always it's been an absolute pleasure
thanks for your time but watch forever
see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]